i'll go on mute
okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
and i can see that we have a whole bunch
of questions left over here
from previous times so let me try and
start addressing some of these
the question here from memes about
not theory some question about what is
not theory
and um things about electron charges and
not theory which
it's a little bit less clear but let's
first of all start talking about uh
not theory and i realize i
i should have a prop for this let's see
i don't think i have a ready prop what
can i use as a prop
well i could this is very dangerous i
could use some part of the computer
cable here
as a prop not theory is about
what does it take to make this
knotted what does it mean for something
to be knotted
it means if you have an ordinary knot it
means
if you pull on the ends it doesn't just
go straight
it's kind of twisted up in the middle
now
in it is an interesting thing that
uh for example if you try to draw a knot
in two dimensions if you try and just
draw a picture of a knot
flat you can't do that in general
without having lines that cross over
that lines where the same line has to be
in the same place on the page
two lines crossing over but you can
make a knot in three dimensions any knot
that you have that's in some
line that's twisted up and knotted
together you can always
what's called in mathematics embed that
in three dimensions you can always
render that knot as something that
exists in three dimensions
now actually if you want to get very
fancy math you can go
beyond that and you can say imagine
instead of having a line that's all
twisted up
i have some whole surface that's all
twisted up how many dimensions do i need
to go to
so that i can embed that surface without
ever having to have something where
two things are at the same place and
there's a whole sort of
hierarchy of sort of generalizations of
knots that aren't just a single
line being twisted up but they are
something like a surface being twisted
up and so on
but that's a more complicated thing
let's talk about ordinary knots
so the first question is when
are two knots equivalent that is
when what does it mean for knots to be
equivalent well it means that
without untying the thing you can just
sort of
you've got two things where you say this
is how my piece of string
winds around but the those
those two those two versions are winding
around you can
continuously get from one to the other
just move the string
you don't have to untie it you don't
have to uh
you know you don't have to kind of um uh
you can you can keep the ends fixed in
place
and you could just be messing around
with the inside part
and so you don't ever have to get those
ends
and unravel untie the thing and go back
to something different so the most
trivial knot
is usually called by mathematicians the
unknot and the unknot
is something that isn't knotted it's
just like you have the piece of string
and it's straight and there's no knot in
it
the first non-trivial art is to think of
the truffle knot
which is um uh oh gosh i'm
i'm not good at this but it's it's the
first way of knotting things together
and so one question is are there only a
limited number of knots or are there an
infinite number of possible knots that
are inequivalent
so remember knots are equivalent if you
can just continuously deform from one
knot to another
so the way mathematicians usually deal
with knots is a little bit impractical
but it makes things a little bit simpler
when one deals with knots and pieces of
string
rope or whatever else it is um one it
usually has two
ends that are free and you're able to
like pull on those ends
but for mathematicians they usually join
those ends together so the unknot
is actually like a circle of of string
rather than a straight line of string
and the truffle knot is then a sort of
twisting of that circle
so there's a question of for example one
one basic question would be are there an
infinite number of knots
that is can you just keep doing
more sort of uh twistings of things
that are inequivalent the answer yes
they're an infinite number of knots
that wasn't known even uh
like 130 40 years ago that was not known
that there were an infinite number of
knots
and it was um it was the whole
classification of knots that was done
so for example i think the uh the early
books of knot classifications were knots
up to eight crossings
so crossings means when you if you were
to draw the knot
in a plane how many times do the
the the lines cross over and
when in general when you draw a knot you
could have many many many crossings over
but there's a minimum number of
crossings over a sort of a best drawing
of the knot
that has the minimum number of crossings
over and uh i think the the early
classifications have got up to about not
size eight
so now another question is can you tell
whether two knots are equivalent if
somebody just shows you
this is two configurations of string
what does it take
to show that those two knots are
equivalent that turns out to be a really
hard problem
it turns out that um uh in
in general uh let's see
i think well in the classification of
mathematical problems
it is given a a sort of a a version of
the
of the knot where you just have straight
lines and you're you're making the knot
out of sort of straight pieces of
string i think the the problem of
determining not equivalence is certainly
what's called mp complete
and uh yes that's right that's right so
so
in other words there is a to determine
whether two knots
are the same there it is sort of
exponentially hard to do that if you've
represented the knot
as a so you've got these two
configurations of string and they're
both represented just by these sort of
discrete
jumps so you have a string going
straight in the x direction let's say
then it goes up in the y direction that
goes in z direction so you've got
a bunch of straight segments and let's
say you've got
uh n straight segments then in general
to determine whether these two knots are
equivalent you're essentially having to
make a separate sort of move to each of
those segments
and so it's sort of exponential in the
number of segments to determine whether
these two knots are equivalent
at least that's the best known algorithm
i don't think it's known for sure
well i think it's known i think it's
known to be mp complete which means that
if you could solve the problem not
equivalence you could solve
a whole bunch of other problems in in uh
in computational problems so it's
probably really really hard
um probably irreducibly hard so to speak
but so first question is are two knots
equivalent so
a bunch of progress was made about uh 30
years ago now
um in in this question of r2 knots
equivalent
and what was done was there were a
series of not
polynomials that were invented so
discovered i should say
and so what that is is given given a
knot with some structure
the question is is there some aspect of
that knot
that will be unchanged in all possible
deformations of that knot
um and the answer is that there were
these polynomials found
which are characteristic of the knot
itself
and don't change as you deform the not
so let me give you an analogy so in
topology
uh topology is kind of this area of
mathematics that's about the general
shapes of things
so in topology there's this idea of the
genus of an object
so for example a sphere has genus zero
genus is basically the number of holes
in the object
so sphere has genus zero a doughnut with
one hole
or a taurus has genus one uh
a doughnut with two holes has genus two
okay why is this relevant
because the genus of an object doesn't
really depend on the detailed geometry
of the object you can take the sphere
let's say it's a piece of uh piece of
dough or something you can
you can squash it any way you want so
long as you don't make a hole in it
it's still genus zero but it's it is
that these are topologically equivalent
when anything which is
which is sort of the thing without a
hole in it is topologically equivalent
to the thing to that to the sphere and
and so it's the same
same kind of thing with knots you're
asking when are two
differently configured knots in a sense
topologically equivalent
it's a little bit different notion but
it's the same general idea
and one way to characterize that just
like genus number of holes
is a way to characterize the overall
topology of things so there are these
not
polynomials that allow you to
characterize the
the sort of the shapes of knots and
there are a few of these not polynomials
known about three or so
famous ones and you might say well okay
so that will allow you to tell whether
two knots are equivalent but no it
doesn't work that way
because two knots that
are inequivalent must have different
not polynomials but two knots that are
equivalent
i'm sorry two knots that are equivalent
must have the same not polynomial
but two knots that are different may not
have different not polynomials
so if there are two knots where they're
just deformations of each other they
must have the same not polynomial by the
way that not polynomials are constructed
but if you have um uh
uh but if you have two knots that are
different they might happen to have a
collision and not polynomials
so you can't tell that they're different
and so that's why even knowing about not
polynomials which are a pretty clever
idea
it doesn't give you information about
this not equivalence problem
so one question is
you know it's sort of interesting
mathematics to study knots and not
theory
but um uh there were reasons for example
in physics
why people thought about um thought
about that
and there was a theory about
um but this was in the late 1800s about
1880s
it was a very charming theory so at the
time
people thought that the universe was
full of this thing that they called
ether just like you know the
in in in our atmosphere there's
there's air it's a bunch of molecules
bouncing around
and when we make a sound wave a sound
wave is compression and rarefaction
uh uh fronts in the air so when we talk
you know we're making
sound which is compression uh
compression decompression of the air
going out in this kind of wave um and
that's how sound is carried
people thought in a very victorian name
they called it the luminiferous ether
the light carrying ether and that was
thought that there was this
thing they didn't really know how it
worked there was thought that there was
this thing called the ether
that was a um
the thing that would carry light waves
as air carries sound waves and so it was
thought that sort of the universe was
full of such a thing
uh it sort of got the the around 1900
this thing called the michaelson molly
experiment kind of proved that
in some sense there wasn't anything
really quite like ether
and that's what led to the invention of
special relativity and so on in 1905
etc but and needless to say in the way
that science often works
there really are things rather
equivalent to ether that exists today in
the universe
but that's a different story anyway back
in the day
1880-ish people thought there was this
thing that the luminiferous ether
that sort of through was throughout the
universe they also
were just discovering atoms and they
were discovering that the different
chemical elements
were all different uh different kinds of
atoms
they didn't know what was different
between those different kinds of atoms
that waited another 30 years or so
before people started understanding
about protons and neutrons and different
atomic nuclei and
all those kinds of things to understand
what was the difference between a
hydrogen atom
and a lead atom or something what was
the difference between those things
so it was a very charming theory that
maybe all these different kinds of atoms
are just different knots in the ether
maybe these atoms are the the the way
that matter exists is as sort of this
knot
in the ether and so that started just to
fill in
uh you know for historical interest i
mean the uh
person called kelvin uh william thompson
was an
inventor also the kelvin scale of
temperature is named after him
uh he was one of the people involved in
this another one was james
maxwell who was um uh the creator of
maxwell's equations for electromagnetism
those those two were big on this idea of
of um
uh you know atoms might be knots and
ether and so that might sort of reduce
the problem of
why that why are there 92 elements let's
say or
or whatever um you know why are there
this number of distinct kinds of atoms
oh it's because there are a certain
number of distinct kinds of knots
they didn't know they were even at the
time they didn't know they're an
infinite number of distinct possible
knots
and so a uh a childhood friend of
maxwell's actually
named tate um was the first person who
who started
uh classifying knots and tried to figure
out just how many knots
how many different kinds of knots there
were because people thought atoms might
be
things like knots now needless to say
uh in the way that you know that theory
was sort of discredited
and people said no actually atoms are
made of protons and neutrons and
electrons and
so on and the luminiferous ether doesn't
exist and that's all gone
it turns out in our uh now that we
understand
in our recent theory of physics that we
understand a lot more about how space
and time
is created and so on particles like
electrons and so on they're not quite
knots in the structure of space time but
there's something a little bit like that
um which we don't yet understand
completely um but they are
essentially topological obstructions so
to speak
in in in that um uh in the structure of
space-time
well you know knots have had a whole
long history
in in their use in physics for example
uh and other areas sort of it's a big
question
for dna for example it's a long you know
our dna
is like a whole meter long each dna
molecule
inside our uh inside ourselves if you if
you just pulled it out
it will be a meter long thing but it's
curled up very tightly
um inside each cell in our body and uh
when it curls up those sort of questions
does it get knotted
does it not get knotted um there's a
there's a bunch of issues there
um there also are questions
um it turns out okay so
this question of sort of uh uh how
things exist
um okay this sort of topological
question let me give you an example if
you have a fluid like water
you can have a vortex in the fluid you
have this little whirlpool
that's going in the fluid and the
whirlpool lasts quite a while
if the it eventually the sort of the
internal friction in the fluid so-called
viscosity will damp out that vortex
if it wasn't for viscosity the fluid
will just keep going around in line like
in a circle like that and so the center
of that
that vortex is a tube that is
essentially a line so effectively what's
happening is
in the in the fluid there's this thing
that's going around the circle
and defining where that circle where
that going around the circle goes
there's the core of the vortex is
defines a line
so one of the questions you can ask is
could there be a knotted
vortex tube in a fluid and i think such
things were recently produced
very recently last year or two people
finally managed
to make kind of knotted vortex tubes and
fluids
uh where you can have like when you have
a smoke ring for example if you
if you like uh make a make a smoke ring
um you can uh um
uh that that's a that's a vortex it's a
slightly more complicated kind of vortex
that's a torah emotion of the fluid
that's in kind of a tourist
shape again it's using this kind of
ideas of topology
to have something which is a stable
structure that
in in the fluid and there are other
places where you can get these kind of
knots and things potentially forming uh
for example in the early universe you
can potentially have it that's actually
getting us in a
in a complicated story there about um uh
the
the kind of the the formation of kind of
um
areas of the early universe that have
different structure and have sort of
topological
uh defects that are associated with
things like vortices
so that was a a very brief um uh
description of um
not theory in its life and times not
theory has become
it's a it's a slightly slightly off the
beaten path in some ways
uh thing in mathematics but it has many
connections that have been found
to some very core ideas and mathematics
to do with geometry and topology and so
on
okay um
let's see
questions here um
okay there's a question from heather
here
why does computer code involve math why
isn't it just a
set of linear instructions that
sometimes hop around
like kind of choose your own adventure
book well so there's a big question
about how we should tell computers what
to do
because any computer
has a certain set of built-in
instructions a certain set of built-in
things it knows how to do the so-called
machine code of the computer
and the typical computers might have a
few hundred
kinds of operations that they
intrinsically know how to do
like they intrinsically know how to add
two numbers together
they intrinsically know how to take
a piece of data and store it in a
certain memory location in the computer
they intrinsically know how to get uh
something from a particular memory
location in the computer
and then add it to something else and so
on
so there's a question of
what's the when we tell computers what
to do
how close are we to that machine code of
what computers
intrinsically know how to do and i've
spent a large part of my life
trying to build computational language
which
is kind of more on the human side than
it is on the how the computer is built
side that is it's more on the how do
humans want to
describe things in computational terms
than it is about how the computer
intrinsically knows how to do those
particular kinds of operations
and so a great example of that is let's
say you have
a list of numbers just got you know 100
numbers
list of numbers or a list of images
doesn't really matter
list list of things and you want to do
an operation on each one of those things
so in our language and more from
language
um the way you do that you can take
any operation let's say it's image and
you want to i don't know
uh turn it upside down
you know there's some function image
reflect
that would do that um the or image
rotate
whatever that would do that um
and so what you do is in our language
you just
say take that image rotate operation and
just apply it to this whole list
map it across this whole list just in
one gulp
your spell you as you think about it
just saying i want to apply image rotate
to this whole list of things i want to
map it across this whole list of things
okay i'm done okay so if you are
thinking about what does the computer
actually do
to achieve that well the answer is the
computer goes in a loop
it says let me let me apply that
operation to the first thing on the list
okay i've done that let me apply it to
the second thing on the list third thing
in the list and so on
it it goes through this whole series of
operations
to apply things to different parts of
the list now
you know what i believe is that the the
best way for humans
to kind of get the furthest in thinking
about how to compute things
is all they have to think about is i'm
mapping this function over the whole
list
boom i'm done not oh i've got to make
this
this thing which goes this thing to this
thing to this thing
and eventually i'll reassemble the whole
list out of these pieces that i've made
and then that's what we have but so when
when you think about what is the
computer actually doing inside
well it's kind of complicated it's got
to say well i'm starting off with
i've got the initial list i've got the
final list the final list has nothing in
it initially
initial list has 100 things in it then
i've got this
this program that says pick up the first
thing do my operation
put it in the new list pick up the
second thing
do the operation append it to the new
list that i've got it's kind of a messy
complicated
thing and in in the instructions and the
machine code of the computer
it's probably a whole bunch of
instructions in the machine code
to do this kind of thing so a very
common type of operation that one does
in computers is to say do this then do
this then do this then do this
but the thing i just described is a loop
it says
do this then do the same thing again
with some small change like do the same
thing again but now it's being done to
the second element in the list the third
element in the list and so on
and so it's a very common mechanism that
exists in the machine code of computers
to be able to do that kind of looping
how is it achieved
what's happening is the program that the
computer is running
is just like data stored in the memory
of the computer
but that data instead of being like for
example a table of numbers or a piece of
text or something
that data that's stored is
uh it's the machine code and it is
stored in the form
op code operand so the op code might be
operation number 700 well operation
number
15 let's say is add two numbers
so it'll be like a 15 and then it's like
the first number to add
the second number to add or the
locations in memory to get the first
number and the second number and so on
um and so that is like data could be
you know if you didn't know what it was
it just looked like a bunch of numbers
but actually it corresponds to a program
to tell the computer in machine code
what to do
and so it's as the computer then
executes that program
it has to say it's going to go down line
by line through that program
saying now i do this now i execute this
op code now i go to the next line and i
execute this op code
okay so there's a thing called the
program counter which is basically a
thing that says
which place in this program are you
now executing so the typical thing is
that the program counter
just goes up by one so it executes one
step in the program then it goes up by
one executes the next step and so on
so there's this notion of jump
instructions which say
change the program counter you just
reach the end of this sequence of
instructions
now go back five steps with the program
account so reset the program counter
to the program counter minus five and
then then it will start re-recomputing
those things again
so a typical very typical thing is uh
operations like
uh existed even on calculators uh
decrement skip on zero so that that
means
you'll have some some uh
variable some some uh place in memory
where you're storing the number and uh
you'll get to this instruction
that says um uh
that is a um
that just subtracts one from that number
you're storing
and decrements skip on zero means
usually we just extracted subtract one
and then you do the next instruction
but uh decrement skip on zero will mean
if you subtract one and the answer you
get is zero
then skip the next instruction and go to
the one after that so it's kind of
messing around with a program counter
that's telling you how to do that so
this is unbelievably low level
operations of computers
this is how the you know the wiring that
the low-level
electronics of a computer works it is
far away from the way that people i
think should be thinking about how to
interact with computers
um although it is a shocking fact that
that most of the programming languages
are still operating at the level of tell
the computer exactly what to do go
through this loop
you know append things to a list rather
than this sort of higher level
way where it's like yes it the person
can understand what the computer should
do
now it's up to the people who build the
technology
to make that all just work rather than
the human have to
having to go way down to the level of
the computer so to speak and say
this is the detail of what you have to
do
now the question here
is so so what are like for example let's
take this question about
how you're dealing with elements in the
list what do you do with elements in the
list so one thing you can do
what what are the sort of high-level
operations that you can do
with something like that so one high
level operation is to say
let's apply this function let's say
image rotate
to every element in the list that's
mapping across this list
another thing you might do is let's say
it's a list of numbers that you have
another thing you might do is to say
take some function
and just use all those numbers as inputs
to the function so let's say the
function is plus
then you're just using all the numbers
in the list as inputs to that function
okay so that whole list is just plus
plus plus plus
it just all compresses to the sum of
those numbers so that's another
kind of operation usually called
applying a function to a list
so then there are other kinds of
operations that you can do
like here's one that's a little trickier
this is
essentially an accumulate operation
where you say
i want to take a list and it's let's say
it's got numbers in it
and what i want to do is i want a new
list that is
always the cumulative sum of the numbers
in the previous list
so what you're doing is you've got your
first list and then
the elements in the second list you're
saying the first element is just the
first element of the first list the
second element
is the first element plus the second
element
the third element is first element plus
second element plus third
element uh that operation is usually
called folding a function into a list
um and so there are a series of these
kinds of operations
and this is the story of so-called
functional programming
is the the construction of these kinds
of operations where you're taking a
function and for example
doing things um to uh uh
to a list um and uh
um the thing that um
um um
is uh
let's see i'm confused by something okay
the the thing that
um uh um
is is sort of a
a way to think about computation this
kind of idea of
functions being applied to lists and how
that all works
that's the story of functional
programming it is it can be
a little difficult to sort of wrap your
brain around at first once you get it
it's incredibly powerful and for example
for me i i just think in those terms and
i can just start typing
it's you know a fold list of a nest list
or whatever whatever whatever
um and uh i don't really have to think
in detail i never have to think about
what's happening with the individual
elements of the thing it just sort of
all
it's just i think of it in kind of one
go and
uh that's that's a very powerful thing
to be able to do
um and uh that's kind of the story of of
the sort of higher level description
of the computational process beyond the
level of do this
than that than that and make a loop and
so on
all right there was a question here
um question here from
mikhail what type of computer logic is
the most efficient binary
ternary etc oh interesting you asked
that question because i was literally
just wondering about that yesterday
uh tell you a story so
most computers they
operate most essentially all modern
computers
operate in binary what that means is
you take a number like 7 for example and
you represent that
not in base 10 uh
let's say number 17 for example you
represent that not in base 10
but in base 2 so 17 is 7 ones
plus 110 okay
in base 2 let's say
7 would be equal to 1 1 plus 1
2 plus 1 2 squared which is 4.
and so 17 would be equal to uh
well it's it's 1 2 to the fourth which
is 16
plus 1. okay so
and you can represent any number as any
integer for example as just a series of
zeros and ones
where you're taking it's a positional
notation
where the the position of the one
is telling you uh is there is there one
two to the whatever or not okay so
so that's the way computers tend to
represent everything
it's just in binary in sequences of ones
and zeros
okay so when a computer has to do
operations
it has to uh take these things
represented in binary
and and uh uh
do do operations on those binary bits
and so the standard operations that are
done
are the operations of boolean algebra
which are the operations of logic
which are things where you where you
equate or you consider zero to be
uh uh false or off and one to be true
or on and then you say uh if you combine
two things you can say the and of them
which means are they both
true is is a and b
both both true so that means that true
and
true is true but true and false
that's false or you can have uh
or if if if it's
true or false that will still be true
and true or true it's still true false
or
false that's false so
it turns out that you can
make up sort of arbitrary logical
operations
by combining ands and ors and knots and
so on
you can also do it by combining just one
operation called nand
um nand is not and i don't think any
human language has a single word for
nand or has a
has a sort of everyday word for nand but
it's the not
of the and so if if you say
um let's see uh
i can't do this as a natural language
but but something like
um it's raining
nand it's sunny
so that means that
that is actually that's a that's a yeah
okay
is it raining is it sunny those are both
uh things which could be true or false
and the nand of those things
is the of the and so it's
it's not both reigning and sunny
that's what that's what um uh that's
what nand of that would mean
so it turns out that just by combining
lots and lots of nands together
you can make all these different
operations so for example
uh let's see which what does
it takes me a while to figure this out i
think that um like for example i think
or
is a combination of like six or seven
nands all together nand of
if you have p and q it's you know nand
of p and q
of nand of q or p of etc etc etc
when you work that all out it comes out
to be p or
q so anyway you can you can make
everything out of nands
and the the the the mathematical
terminology is
nand is functionally complete uh
sometimes somewhat you know
somewhat confusingly it's called
universal but that's a different meaning
from the sort of more formal meaning of
so-called universal computation
so in any case and why is it important
to know that nand is functionally
complete
back when it was first discovered in
1900 to 1910
it was kind of a curiosity though people
got enthusiastic about it
um the reason it's relevant today is
that computers are kind of
all nands the the individual operations
on the microprocessor chip
are all actually they're usually nor
operations which are just like nands but
they're
less famous but they're basically like a
billion
nand operations all combined in
different ways to make all the
operations of logic as we
as we know them okay so that's how
ordinary computers work
okay so the other possibility is instead
of just saying
everything is a is a bit one or zero
you could say let's have things be what
are sometimes called trits
ternary bits where it's 0 1
or 2 or you can think of it as minus one
zero and one if you want to
and that would be like thinking of a
number in base three
rather than in base two and so then the
question is can you make up
logic that is like the analog of and
but uh and the analog of nand and so on
for trips instead of bits
and i have to say i do not immediately
know
um how that works and i don't know
immediately what the functionally
complete operations
for ternary logic are and i was just
thinking about this yesterday
and thinking i should write the very
simple program to find that out
part of the reason i was thinking about
it yesterday is because i was trying to
track down the history
of some particular kind of ideas
and that history finds its way through
the soviet union
in about 1960-ish
time frame and it turns out that in the
soviet union
there were a bunch of computers made
that were ternary computers
that were computers that were based on
this three-level logic
um and uh those computers i think was
one called the saturn or something
was made around um around 1958 or so
i was a fairly early computer um and
uh there was a period of time when
basically
computers in russia tended to be used
base three
rather than base two um that
kind of decayed eventually that that
started copying american
ibm 360 computers and that no longer was
the ternary computers kind of went
extinct but the question
still sort of remains people said
mathematically the ternary computers
were really interesting
but i don't know enough about them so i
can't really say whether whether that's
a
a good way to do things it was it was
certainly said that it was and i
i just don't know i haven't haven't
worked it out
um there's a question from leonardo uh
saying that all boiling functions can be
constructed from nand is it true from
any other simple boolean function
it's also true of nor nor is kind of
trivially
related to nand so for two input boolean
functions
there are only two functionally complete
there are 16 possible boolean functions
with two inputs and an or not and
and xor and so on and so on and so on
there are
there are two inputs and for each of the
two values of those two inputs
that's four possibilities there's one
possible output so that means that two
to the four possible complete functions
were 16 possible functions and of those
16 functions
two are functionally complete nand and
no
so now you can ask questions like what
about three input boolean functions
um and actually that was uh uh
there's a person named emil post who um
uh who we happen to be about to do a
kind of
uh centenary celebration of something
that he
worked on posts problem of tag uh next
week
um and uh anyway emil post was was uh
interested in the three input boolean
functions
and worked out a little bit about when
were there functionally complete
three input boolean functions um
actually i worked on that
and then completely independently my
youngest son worked on that
not knowing that i'd worked on it um and
i didn't know that animal posted worked
on it until sometime later
so it's been looked at several times
um and the answer is that there are
of the 256 three input boolean functions
there are a bunch like 15 maybe
that are functionally complete and as
you go
um and there's some that are more
efficiently functionally complete
nand and nor are basically equivalent to
each other um
and uh the ones for um uh for three
inputs
they're um
uh they're a little bit more there's
more diversity in their functional
completeness and i think
uh christopher worked out which one is
most efficiently functionally complete
um it's actually not an easy thing to
work out um
but uh you're basically asking
what are what is the size of program
made from
the three input functionally complete
thing that reproduces all the 256
possible boolean functions with three
inputs and you can figure that out
uh i asked him what about the four input
one he said that's too hard at least
that was a few years ago so maybe maybe
it's possible now
but uh for three inputs we do know what
the most efficient one is
uh but what happens is you go to more
and more inputs
the fraction of functionally complete
functions
actually is like i think it's eventually
like a quarter of all functions
are functionally complete so that's how
that works i don't know the answer for
the
for the um i know it for multiple input
two level
functions i don't know the answer for
the three input functions although now
that i think about it
i think in my book new kind of science i
talked about
the three input logic case and i i'm i'm
now realizing that i
think there's a very good chance that
there's a note in the back of that book
that has the answer to this question
uh that book is today actually is its
19th anniversary
of its publication um and so that means
that whatever work i did on this was
probably 25 years ago
and i remember a page of that book that
is about
uh multi-level logic but i don't
remember what the what the answer to
this
is um
there's a question here from a man how
does nan realize now and well it's very
easy it's
already nand so you don't have to worry
about how you make a noun out of nand
but it is the case that many
combinations of nands
simplify to just a single noun so you
can have
and i cannot possibly do this in my head
but like for example
it could be that nand of p and q the
nand of that
with q of the nand of p and q and so on
when you untangle that it just comes out
to be nand p and q
so there's an infinite collection of
expressions see
let me give you an analogy let's say
that you have algebraic variables
x and y and you're trying to make the
expression
x plus 3y for example
well you can make that by saying x plus
y plus y plus y
we're going to say it by making x plus x
minus x plus y minus x plus y
plus y something like that there are
actually an infinite number of algebraic
expressions that you can make
that all simplify to the same that all
have the same value
x plus three y and the same thing
happens with nands
you can have the sort of infinite
collection of sort of nested nands and
so on that all collapse
down to just now to p and q so it's sort
of the
same way that that works um
okay let's uh
well there's a question here
um question from simple why are we only
considering first order derivatives of
position velocity and second order
acceleration
why are higher derivatives not relative
apparently
okay that's a that's an interesting that
that question has a
has a much stronger sting in its tail
than you might have imagined
um okay let's see if i can untangle that
so first question is let's say
so this is sort of the part of the basic
story of calculus
the there's this idea i'm at this
position
okay great position call it x
it's you know i'm at position 3.7
i've got a line and i'm i'm numbering
off where everything is
i've got my position x is 3.7 okay
now let's say imagine that position
changes with time
okay so we're asking how fast does that
position change with time
how long will it take me to get to 3.7
plus a little tiny bit
3.7 plus another tiny bit so
that's asking me the rate of change of x
with time and the rate of change of
position with time
is velocity that's telling me how fast
am i going
how how much am i changing my position
per unit of time okay so that's velocity
so then the next thing we can ask is
okay great we're
we're changing our position as a
function of time we can also ask
how fast are we changing how fast we
change our position
as a function of time that's the
so-called second derivative of the
position
the velocity is the first derivative the
first
rate of change of position with respect
to time
but now we can ask what's the rate of
change of
of velocity with time and that duration
so in principle when you put your foot
on a gas and a car
it's it's accelerating the car it's
making the car
it's putting more force into pushing the
car forward
and newton's second law says the force
that you push something with is its mass
times its acceleration
so it's saying you put force on
something and it causes acceleration it
causes
the velocity to change at a certain rate
so you keep putting that force on
something let's say
um this is you know you're trying to
make some starship go to the
next star if you just keep putting the
same force on it
for a long time for a year you keep
making something accelerate
it's going to be going really fast at
the end of that year because
it's just progressively uh increasing
the velocity
as a function of time because you're
you're pushing it with that acceleration
so uh position velocity acceleration
all widely used widely studied we talk
about them all the time
the next derivative the third derivative
is the rate of change of acceleration
with time
how much does the acceleration change
with time so for example
let's say you're putting your foot on
the gas in a car and let's
say you are gradually putting your foot
on the gas
as you push your foot on the gas it
increases the acceleration of the car
but as you gradually put your foot on
the gas the rate at which you put your
foot on the gas
that's the rate of change of
acceleration with time
now the thing that's most common is when
you have a rapid
change of acceleration and usually the
name for that is it's usually called the
jerk
of um how much does something jerk how
much does
it uh the rate of change of acceleration
is like
when there's a high rate of change of
acceleration it's like
uh in a car it's like it jerks you back
or forward or whatever
um so the rate of change of acceleration
is a single
jerk it's often called jerk um
it's uh it's not particularly widely
studied
um the so now the question
here has to do with um
yes okay this question is a bit tricky
actually
okay so fundamental fact known to
galileo
in the 1600s is that or believed by
galileo
is that in some sense if you are
moving at a certain velocity everything
can happen
relative to your relative to you
in the same way that would happen if you
were at rest so imagine you're in
a train car and it's
all everything's blacked out and the
train car is moving perfectly on a track
at a certain velocity certain certain
speed
and you're doing all kinds of things in
this train car you're having your
breakfast whatever else
you can't tell as you dig into that
uh you know piece of breakfast nothing
about you digging into that piece of
breakfast
uh can you tell any difference about the
speed of the train car it could be going
at 10 miles an hour or 90 miles an hour
so long as it's perfect and you're not
hearing a clickety clack from the track
or something like this
you you can't tell as you're eating your
breakfast you can't tell how fast the
train car is going
and that's a general principle that was
originally talked about just in terms of
ordinary mechanical kinds of things
uh the theory of relativity einstein's
special theory of relativity
is all about how you can't tell even
uh well it's it's that the speed of
light
will always appear constant however fast
you're going
if you're shining a flashlight then you
might think
oh if i shine a flashlight and i'm going
really fast relative to sort of the
relative to the universe or something
relative to my train track
then my flashlight uh would be would
have to
would be the effective speed of light is
the speed of the train plus the speed
that the light comes
out at which will be bigger than the
speed of light and so the key
idea which actually was part of
maxwell's equations and then
kind of the the consistency of that was
what came out in special relativity
was the idea that actually when you
shine that flashlight even if you're
going really fast
half the speed of light the light coming
out of your flashlight will still only
be going at the speed of light
how can that possibly work well this was
the idea of special relativity
the idea is that can work just fine if
you redefine your notions of length and
time
so in other words that that the light is
coming out at the speed of light
but you uh you're redefining
what your there is a contraction in time
the contraction in length there's a
dilation in time
associated with how fast you're going
relative to somebody who's at rest
we can explain how that works actually
in our theory of physics
we finally have a very straightforward
way to understand time dilation
to understand the idea that if you're
going fast
then you're effectively uh if you think
about
what the way that you perceive time
it's about you are sort of your brain is
operating
your brain is kind of computing things
at a certain speed
and in a sense the way that that
computation is working
it's it's changing things in the
universe
as a result of the things that you're
thinking about in your brain
and what you realize is that when you
move
when you move from one place in space to
another you're also changing things in
the
in sort of the the way that in the
structure of the universe
and you kind of have a choice you can
change things in the way in the
structure of the universe
by moving to a different place in space
or you can change things by just
evolving in time
and time dilation comes about when
you're moving in space
you are effectively using up your
computation
in the process of that motion in space
and so you don't have sort of as much
computation to use up
in in going forward in time and so time
in a sense appears to go more slowly for
you
because you already used up a bunch of
the sort of computation
that you might have used to evolve in
time by moving in space
well in any case so in in relativity
uh there's sort of this idea that if you
are
if there's no acceleration if you're
just moving
at a certain velocity you can't tell
what velocity you're moving at you can't
tell about it with mechanics you can't
tell about it with electromagnetism
etc you just can't tell okay but as soon
as there's acceleration
you can tell imagine you're eating your
breakfast and so on
and the train car is suddenly coming to
a halt okay we all know
then your breakfast gets thrown to one
side of the train car
that's because unlike with with um
uh uh with velocity with speed
where you just can't tell you're merely
going along and you're going at the same
speed and you're
you know your knife and fork are going
at the same speed you just can't tell
what speed you're going at
as soon as there's acceleration splat
you're on the you know your breakfast is
on the
on the floor type thing okay so the next
thing that happened in sort of the
history of physics was einstein's
general theory of relativity
and that involves this thing called the
principle of equivalence and the
principle of equivalence
says you can't tell the difference
between
the acceleration of the train car and
your breakfast falling on the floor and
going splat
because of acceleration and your
breakfast falling on the floor and going
splat because of gravity
in other words if somebody uh had tipped
the train car up
and there was gravity was pulling your
breakfast down in some direction
um then that is the the
there is no difference between
acceleration and
the force and the effect of gravity okay
so that's that's the um
so that's the the principle of
equivalence the idea of so-called
general
uh general relativity is this idea that
a gravitational field
is equivalent you can't tell the
difference between gravitational field
and acceleration
okay so now the question is being asked
here
is what is the analog of that for
uh for change of acceleration well the
answer is
that the case of of ordinary
acceleration
is the case of a uniform gravitational
field
so on the surface of the earth the earth
is big enough that the gravitational
field is more or less uniform
it uniformly just pulls things down in a
straight line towards the center of the
earth
but in in general the gravitational
field doesn't have to be uniform if the
earth
if we look at the earth from a long way
away we'll see the gravitational field
is sort of going out
in all directions from the earth if we
were to look at
um if we were to look at the
gravitational field around a black hole
for example an ordinary black hole that
isn't
isn't spinning around rapidly has
gravitational field but also just sort
of goes out like a hedgehog
but a spinning black hole has a more
complicated configuration of
gravitational field that involves
things like frame dragging which is sort
of a a
a sort of a vortex like thing in the
gravitational field and so on
so there are more complicated
gravitational fields that you can get
by having more complicated
configurations of of mass
that produce gravitational field and and
so
what happens is in in a uniform
gravitational field
that's where this principle of
equivalence that says it's just like
uniform acceleration
okay but in a more complicated
gravitational field
you can have something that is like
other configurations
of acceleration and even uh change of
acceleration and so on
as a as a result of these these uh more
complicated structure of gravitational
field so
something like the principle of
equivalence would be true
for this more complicated kind of
configuration
but you would say so the question is can
you invent
a configuration of the gravitational
field that
will be indistinguishable from jerk from
acceleration
from from change of acceleration and so
i think you could do that let me think
about this for a second
um okay so i suspect
i think for a second um
well there's a small effect of that
yeah okay so there will be a uh
it won't be linear change of
acceleration
how would you get that uh
well let me explain what i was thinking
of so
on the surface of the earth the
acceleration due to gravity
the acceleration that is the equivalent
of the gravitational field
things accelerate at 9.8 roughly meters
per second per second
so that means think every second things
are going faster by 9.8 meters per
second
so in principle if you drop something
from a big height
for a while it will go it will it will
keep going faster and faster and faster
and faster
and every second of the time it falls it
will go faster by 9.8 meters per second
now that's not really how it works
because
um in air there's air resistance and so
actually things
reach a terminal velocity that isn't
even very fast in the air
there's a famous experiment done by one
of the apollo astronauts
who picked who had a feather and a rock
that he took to the moon
and uh the moon of course has doesn't
have an atmosphere
it's just a vacuum and he drops the
feather and the rock
and needless to say they they fall at
the same speed
and uh that's fortunate because
otherwise there's no way a spacecraft
would ever have gotten to the moon
because
all the calculations are based on that
idea but any case
so at the surface of the earth
everything just falls
9.8 meters per second per second but as
you go further away from the earth
the gravitational field gets that's less
less and less
and by the time you're at the um by the
time you're far away like at the
position well like like the
the um uh let's say the position of the
moon you go out to the position of i
don't know
mars or something the gravitational
field the gravitational effect of the
earth is pretty small by the time you
get out to the position of mars
it goes down like an inverse square law
one over the square of the distance
and so what that means is that
acceleration that you get by something
falling towards the earth
that acceleration is changing as you get
closer to the earth because
the gravitational field instead of it
being 9.8 meters per second per second
it'll be you know at some point it'll be
one meter per second per second
then go even further away it's 0.1
meters per second per second
so that means there's a change of
acceleration as you get
closer to the to the earth that change
of acceleration will not be
it'll be according to this inverse
square law thing it will not be a linear
change of acceleration
um of the kind that you would get from
the third derivative of a position
so the question is what is the
configuration of masses
what what shape would the earth have to
have such that its gravitational field
will produce a uniform change of
acceleration
the uniform change of gravitational
field as a function of
of position and let me think how you
work that out
let's see we need to invert uh
how to do this um
ah let me think um
so i think hmm
i don't think i can compute this in real
time i have this vague feeling that some
conical arrangement
of mata would have this feature that
somehow
as you get if you're in a cone and as
you're falling towards the apex of the
cone
that you might have this effect that you
have just a pure um
uh sort of increase of acceleration with
time a pure
so-called x triple dot third derivative
of the position
so in another case so the answer is i
think that with a certain could
it just doesn't happen to be a very
popular configuration of masses
that lead to a third derivative of
position
but you certainly could make one and uh
you could be discussing it and i i think
um yeah that's just not one that really
comes up very much
in general relativity in the theory of
gravity uh but
it could in principle that that um
uh could exist and you're asking why
they're not relative well
the answer is they are they still obey
this principle
that you can substitute change of
acceleration for gravitational fields
just a more complicated gravitational
field
than for pure acceleration and uh
yeah that was that was one that required
non-non-elementary knowledge of physics
so
uh all right let's see um
you know i was asking what derivative of
acceleration i i think it's usually
called jerk
um i think the um uh
that comes up derivatives of
acceleration are not particularly common
but it comes up in things like
drones and helicopters and that's a
that's a
thing that ends up being uh let's think
how does this work
the issue is if you as a human
are controlling something let's say
you're making your car
go faster okay people understand how to
put their foot on the gas
and make the car go faster but it turns
out
for some kinds of control you need to be
controlling the third derivative
and it's pretty hard for humans to kind
of get in mind how that works
um so that that tends to be a limitation
that's why for example
uh you know drones which uh you know
have automatic flight controllers
that determine you know make this rotor
go slightly faster so that you the thing
remains stable and and remains kind of
um
uh you know as you push down one side of
your four rotor drone
the thing will just that that rotor will
be running faster and pushing you up
faster humans find it very difficult to
do that kind of control that's why
people tried to build quadrotor devices
um
back you know in the days when they were
using you know internal combustion
engines for that rather than electric
motors now
um it wasn't you know you could have a
human trying to control and humans found
it really difficult
and that had to do with being able to
control the third derivative as i recall
and humans just find that really hard
all right let's see maybe one more
question um and then we should wrap this
up
uh lots of very interesting questions
here sorry
i look forward to tackling the next next
time um
the question from frost here do you
think emotions will emerge out of
intelligence
if computer scientists continue to make
general ai do you think the more general
more intelligent it gets the more
emotional it will get
it's an interesting question so
you know what are human emotions
they are you know human emotions are
kind of like in some sense
we think about things at some rational
level we imagine you know
there's logic we can deduce from that
but then there's this kind of
overlay of and we feel this way about
what we're doing
and what seems to be the case is that
there are in our brains there are
these neurotransmitters that are the
things that are actually responsible for
for taking signals from neuron to neuron
and things like that
and different emotions probably are
associated with
different amounts of those different
neurotransmitters
and we can kind of get a sense of that
people often make up
particularly popular close to 100 years
ago now these kind of
uh these kind of charts that represent
you know the space of emotions
like you can be happy you can be sad you
can be angry you can be content you can
be
uh impatient you can be patient that
maybe isn't an emotion i don't know
you can be you know these these various
kinds of dimensions on which you can
plot you know uh happy versus sad or
something
um you can sort of plot these emotions
and and you you can map those to some
extent onto
you know the smiley faces so to speak
the the uh a famous thing charles darwin
actually did this um
had this book actually called the
expression of emotions in animals and
man
and uh his main observation was uh you
know you can
you know we all have this emotional
reaction we're happy we smile
we're sad we kind of frown and turns out
as darwin claimed animals like dogs and
so on
have similar kinds of facial expressions
of what seemed to be their internal
emotions um
and of course that can be captured to
some extent with you know emoticons you
have the smiley
and you have all of those um uh those
scales that you know often exist of you
know how satisfied were you with this um
uh this customer service you know press
the button from the smiley
it was great to the frowny it was awful
um that's sort of a a representation of
that emotional scale
but so so there's this idea that
emotions are
somehow on these various scales with
some number of dimensions of
of different kind of happy to sad this
to that
and there's some possibility that those
actually correspond to
in the end to levels of
neurotransmitters in our brains
um and uh there's sort of a question
when it comes to animals like cats and
dogs and things
maybe a lot of what is communicable a
lot of what we can
recognize is emotions similar to our
emotions
possibly even because it's the very same
neurotransmitters that are getting
different levels in the brain of the cat
and so on
so so a question is then how does
you know how do emotions relate to kind
of the human experience
how do they relate to the kinds of
things we want ais to do
and um you know i think that that is
to what extent emotions are kind of an
overlay
like you know when you have a piece of
music you have definite notes that
you're playing this note that note that
note
but then you have the sort of the the
instructions you know play it fast play
it with vigor
play it you know tentatively so to speak
or whatever
those are kind of the emotion script
that goes along with the actual
sort of these play these specific notes
and so on and i think that's
a similar way to the way that one might
think about emotion
in the context of what we're normally
thinking about in terms of sort of
uh computational language symbolic ai
these kinds of things
um so i think that's um and when you ask
the question
you know can you teach your computer to
recognize whether that face is happy or
sad yeah it's easy
you know we we have a little function
called facial features that does exactly
that
it can tell you you know it's a happy
face it's a sad face
um you can uh uh it's easy to do
sort of from the outside how does that
affect
how does if you have an ai and you say
okay
i'm gonna give you the ai a piece of
virtual chocolate so be a happy ai
um you know how does that then affect
what the ai does
it's complicated i mean i don't think we
really know at all
how to map sort of the emotional
uh overlay that humans use
about sort of the overlay on thinking
about things into the level of so what's
the answer to that computation i mean
two plus two is always equal to four
whether you're happy or sad
um but something like um uh
you know it might be something like is
this
do i is this a good piece of music
well you know the good piece of music
when you're in a really
upbeat really energetic things are
you know mood might be a different good
piece of music
from the one that's appropriate or that
you consider to be a good piece of music
when you're in a really you know spaced
out tired
down kind of kind of state and so
sort of mapping that stuff onto how
computers should respond to things it's
not a thing that's been much done
i mean that there are various approaches
people talk about um you know affective
computing and things and they talk about
kind of how to how uh in a user
interface for example
how you know if you if you're talking to
the talk to the robot so to speak talk
to the bot
depending on its facial expressions and
whether it seems to be happy or sad
you may respond to it differently it's
kind of the
the human interface may be different if
it looks like you're talking to the bot
and the body is really interesting what
you're saying and the body's smiling a
lot when you
when you tell it this you may respond
differently in terms of how you interact
with that bot
but if if the if the question is will
sort of somehow
the notion the idea of emotions somehow
pop out of kind of what we're doing in
ai i'm not sure i mean i think that
we have to ask in in
in biological evolution you know what
was the role of emotions and i think
probably emotions were an earlier form
of kind of thinking in the following
sense that you know
if you're a if you're
a a mouse or something and
uh things are happening and it's like oh
my gosh something is
chasing me it's like i'm afraid what do
you do if you're afraid you run away
okay whereas the more sophisticated
mouse
will say let me consider that thing that
appears to be chasing me
i believe it is a robotic cat and that
robotic cat
has you know motion that only goes in a
straight line and therefore
i really shouldn't be afraid i'm just
working out
if i go in this place and that place and
the other place i'm just going to avoid
the robotic cat and all the good
so i i kind of think in that
evolutionarily probably
some of the emotions just wash the brain
with serotonin or something
is is kind of you know make make it
respond in a way that's that's
uh it's probably sort of a a lower
version of what
in in humans ends up being sort of
higher thought process it doesn't mean
it's any less real for us humans
but it does mean that it's it's probably
something where in kind of the
we want ais to do things for the sake of
of solving a problem of of some kind
that's a
a well-defined sort of science type
problem it's probably not really a
relevant thing
when we want the the ai's to interface
with humans
well emotions are a big deal for us
humans
and so if we want the ais to do things
which are which are a good match
for how humans uh sort of deal with the
world
then the ais have to have that
capability as well
but it's sort of a capability that
you're kind of i think
it's kind of more of a bolt-on
capability than a natural
progression of if the ai can emulate the
thinking of a human in this way in that
way
then necessarily there will be some sort
of emotional overlay on to that to that
kind of thinking
i kind of suspect it's the other way
around that it's a more primitive form
that um it's kind of like uh you could
and you could teach the ai
you know based on this input i should be
a happy ai or something
but it's it's sort of an overlay and not
part of the sort of detailed processes
of
of of the sort of thinking like activity
of the ai
all right well i should wrap up here for
today um
and uh thank you all very much for lots
of interesting questions
i realize as always as i explain these
things
i um i understand a little bit better
myself
and i hope some of that understanding is
uh useful and interesting to people
but um thanks for joining us here
and uh see you another time